[Music]
hi my name is larry summers i'm a
professor of economics at Harvard
University I'm doing something a little
different than most of the other classes
in this series rather than talking about
a specific area of knowledge rather than
talking about my field of economics I'm
going to talk about knowledge in general
talk about universities talk about ideas
and talk about their importance since
it's going to be a personal perspective
I thought I'd begin by just saying a
little bit about my background I grew up
in an academic family of economists
became an economist was a professor of
economics at MIT and Harvard then went
into government working at the World
Bank in the United States government
ultimately becoming secretary of the
Treasury then served as Harvard's
president for five controversial years
between 2001 and 2006 went back to being
a professor then served as President
Obama's chief economic adviser for the
first two years of his administration
that gives me a perspective on
universities I think and a perspective
on life beyond universities it gives me
also the perspective of an economist and
the perspective more generally of a
social scientist I think that's
something very important and it's
something I want to emphasize if you
think about a high school education you
study English you study literature II
study music you study art if you think
about a high school education you study
biology you study chemistry you study
physics but you don't study social
science in the same way you don't learn
about scientific approaches to how
societies function and how societies
operate
and part of what I'm going to try to
convince you of today is that such
approaches have greatly enhanced our
understanding that understanding them
better is hugely important for your
future
before I say anything else I want to say
something about my philosophy of
Education and my philosophy about why
what we do in universities is so
profoundly important and I'll illustrate
it with this story some years ago I was
fortunate enough to receive an honorary
degree from one of America's great
universities and of course the president
of that University gave the commencement
speech it was a very very good speech at
one point the president said and the
great thing about our university is we
consider every subject we discuss every
question we look at every kind of
evidence we focus on every approach to
analysis and out of that dialogue out of
that debate comes and then the sentence
was completed a greater understanding of
each other's perspective and I felt very
let down when I heard that because I
thought what came out of considering
every argument debating every question
looking at every kind of evidence was a
closer approximation to truth and out of
a closer approximation to truth came
better understanding of our world and
out of better understanding of our world
came a better world and so it is my
strongest conviction that the reason
what you are engaged in is so important
is
cause understanding getting closer to
truth progress is the most important
thing there is for making lives better
for all our people I want to talk about
three things today first I want to talk
about the importance of ideas the
importance of intellectual life second I
want to talk about the importance of
some of some of the trends that are
defining our time I'm gonna do that by
posing a question that we can't know the
answer to but that we can guess at what
will historians say about our time 250
years from now and third I want to take
a perspective on what all this means
for your education what all this means
for the work of universities and
colleges think about what is remember of
any society in the longest run does
anyone remember who ruled England when
Chaucer wrote or when Milton wrote or
when Shakespeare wrote or even when
Dickens wrote their names will be
remembered long after any political
rulers name is remembered does anyone
know who ruled France while the great
Impressionists created their work Isaac
Newton's name will be remembered far
longer than any person of wealth or
fortune Einsteins we concept
zatia of the universe likely will last
longer than almost any monument that
anyone constructs to themselves or to
any triumph as the Harvard scholar how
in Wendla wrote it is for their works of
creation that ultimately civilizations
are remembered and so it is ultimately
when one takes the longest view the
kinds of ideas that you were exposed to
in this course the kind of ideas that
you will be exposed to in the remainder
of your education that are most
important of course for most of us it is
not conceivable that we are gonna create
a sonnet like Shakespeare did or a
painting like Picasso did but what is it
that shapes the way our nation's
function the decisions our nation's make
that can affect the lives of millions of
people
now John Kennedy was not a typical
Harvard undergraduate and he certainly
didn't have a typical post Harvard
career he did write an undergraduate
thesis he had a father who was very
ambitious for him he had access to help
from journalists he published that
thesis under the title why England slept
and it was basically a vicious critique
of Chamberlain's errors of appeasing
Hitler at Munich that set of ideas
shaped u.s. foreign policy for over a
generation the lessons John Kennedy
learned
about international relations the
research he did helped shape his
approaches to how as president of the
United States he would protect America's
national security he learned important
lessons about restraint and but for his
wisdom the Cuban Missile Crisis could
have ended in conflagration he learned
important lessons about resolve about
avoiding the appearance of appeasement
and some believe that those contributed
to the tragic errors of America's entry
into the Vietnam War you can debate the
particular substance of the lessons he
learned what you cannot debate is that
it was his ideas his ideas learned from
his education that shaped the direction
of our nation in much the same way
economists today president today debate
our Great Recession they debate how best
to drive our economy forward they take
it as a given that the objective is to
raise something called the GDP the gross
domestic product you know it wasn't
always thus people didn't know there was
such a thing as the GDP a hundred years
ago until it was conceptualized by
economic research taught to generations
of students generations of students
learned that demand had a great deal to
do with what happened to economies it
says something that the works of the
great British economist John Mayer
canes were taught at Harvard and Yale in
the 1950s but alumni protested that they
were a communist plot in just 20 years
later Richard Nixon one of our most
conservative presidents declared that we
are all Keynesian now to be sure the
world moved away from Keynes's doctrines
as economies changed in the 1980s and
1990s and now with the current downturn
they're moving back in those directions
again the specifics don't matter what
does matter is the basic idea that it is
ideas it is what becomes conventional
wisdom that shapes the choice of nations
we take it for granted in our lives that
there are things that happen consciously
and things that happen unconsciously a
hundred and fifty years ago there was no
idea of the unconscious until Freud
developed such an idea 500 years ago
there was no idea of childhood as we now
conceive it children were thought of as
miniature adults this is life-changing
because of ideas activities that people
think of as the most mundane are
revolutionized by intellectual
sophistication the example I like to
give is Major League Baseball for a
hundred years until about a decade ago
baseball teams chose their players by
hiring Scouts sending former baseball
players out to watch people play
baseball and pick up and try to recruit
strapping strong looking young guys
there's still some of that but now any
successful team drafts based on careful
statistical analysis that found all
sorts of patterns that had never been
noticed before having to do with what
kinds of players play well and what
kinds of players play less well it was
driven by inspiration and the product of
that inspiration was competition
baseball makes progress stores make
progress
and how they sell things we don't think
of it as a source of knowledge or as a
great innovation but I would suggest to
you that the idea of the double-blind
experiment the idea that you test a
medical therapy by giving it to some
people not giving it to other people and
doing a controlled experiment is one of
the most important innovations in
medicine that took place during the 20th
century thought evidence ideas change
progress it's not just at the
civilizational level it's not just at
the level of whole nations but it's at
the level of successful organizations of
every kind and then there's of course
the individual and what determines how
successful individuals are and here too
the evidence is strong and the world has
changed the economic return to being
better educated is far greater than it
was even a generation ago look at the
difference in income between college
graduates and high school graduates but
it's not only the economic return the
gap in life expectancy between those
with more education and those with less
education has doubled as more and more
practices have been discovered that the
educated can follow that improve their
health
and improve their well-being so if you
look at it at every level you're we're
finding that ideas understanding
comprehension their contribution to
progress are becoming that much more
important indeed I would suggest to you
that if one wanted to describe how the
world or at least large parts of the
world have changed over the last sixty
years it has been a movement from a
world that is governed by the idea of
authority to a world that is governed
much more by the authority of ideas and
such a world carries with it
staggering potential but only potential
for those who grasped who use who
cherish and who develop ideas what are
some of the ideas shape our time there's
a way of getting it that question let's
try to think about what a historian 250
years from now will say about this
quarter century or this half century
that we're right now in the middle of if
you think about it we most of us can't
distinguish in a terribly sharp way what
happened between 1675 and 1717 hundred
and 1725 but I think there are some
things they're likely
to note now to be sure there could be
catastrophic events if global climate
change is not contained or managed in
some way how that story plays out could
be the defining feature of history if
nuclear proliferation as the
consequences that some fear some kind of
nuclear conflagration could be what
people remember from our time but those
it doesn't seem to me would be the
things one would expect and instead
there are three aspects of the world all
in the main favorable all in the main
reflecting the power of ideas that are I
believe going to be the legacy of our
time first we now are headed for a truly
global progressing economy and society
if you look at economic history what you
see is that there was essentially no
progress through most of the history of
humanity scholars debate vigorously and
bitterly whether the standards of living
in London in 1800 we're the same as they
had been in the Athens of Pericles
or whether they were 50% greater whether
perhaps even they were a hundred percent
greater but even if they were a hundred
percent greater
a doubling of standards of living over
2,300 years works out to a negligible
annual growth rate the reason they
called it the Industrial Revolution was
that for the first time in all of human
history progress started at a rate where
it was noticeable within a human
lifespan for the first time in all of
human history at the end of a human
lifespan the conditions of life the
conditions of existence were importantly
different than they had been at the
beginning of a human lifetime why did
the Industrial Revolution happen in
England in 1800 reven Brazil in 20 in
2000 or in China or India in 1200 that's
a matter of much debate and much
analysis was it an accident are there
deep reasons these are matters that are
extensively debated but what is not
debated is that the Industrial
Revolution had to do with the
application of scientific ideas to the
basic tasks of growing food making
clothing providing shelter what's not in
doubt is that the Industrial Revolution
was propelled forward by innovations
which were the product of thinking human
beings incentivized to develop better
ways of doing things what is not in
doubt is that the
Industrial Revolution benefited from
emulation and imitation that good ideas
were carried out not just by the person
who had them but by others who saw them
being carried out and emulated success
and what is not in doubt is that
competition argument debate trial and
error pushed all of that forward but the
Industrial Revolution as great as it was
led to growth rates of income growth
changes in standards of living of
perhaps 1% a year perhaps slightly more
over the course of a human lifespan
which in those days was only 40 years
living standards might rise 40 perhaps
50 percent that was unprecedented and
unimaginable relative to anything that
had come before but it was very little
compared to what was to come as the
Industrial Revolution spread across
Europe as America proved to be
particularly innovative particularly
successful in applying technology to
have a culture that particularly
rewarded those who were prepared to do
new things in new ways
you saw progress in the United States at
the end of the 19th century that was
considerably faster perhaps twice as
fast perhaps even a little more than
twice as fast as had ever been seen in
Britain during the Industrial Revolution
and so it was possible to imagine around
the turn of
century that living standards in the
United States would rise by a factor of
three or by a factor of four over the
course of a human lifespan that too was
an immense achievement and it was the
reason that the United States emerged as
a power a great power in the first half
of the 20th century
now think about what's happened in China
in India in other parts of the world
growth rates not of 1% or 2% or 3% but
growth rates of 7% or 8% or 9% Einstein
was said to have said that compound
interest is the most powerful force
known to man at 7% a year growth a
quantity doubles in 10 years
think about what 7% growth means for an
economy it means doubling in one decade
and then doubling in the next decade it
means that with a 70 year lifespan
it is imaginable that living standards
would differ by more than a factor of a
hundred from where they were when a
person was born at the end of a human
lifespan it means that in a decade an
individual goes from walking to having a
bicycle in another decade to a
motorcycle in another decade to an
automobile it means that areas that on
photographs 30 years ago were green rice
fields large gleaming cities are built
today it means that at one point one in
six sky cranes
on planet Earth were
in Shanghai and this is not a matter of
something that is happening in one
corner of the globe close to one in five
people on planet Earth
live in China and close to 40% of the
population of our planet live in China
and in India why are they enjoying this
profound rapid growth again the matter
is studied and debated extensively but
most people would accept that it has a
great deal to do with their being
prepared to open up and to emulate and
to learn from economies from companies
from individuals who are producing in
more sophisticated ways than they have
most people would accept that it has a
great deal to do with a move to systems
in which individuals have an opportunity
to benefit from their own success you
know it has been said that no one ever
washed a rented car and it captures an
important truth that when people own
things when people get the fruits of
success they work harder to produce
success as those societies have opened
up to learn from the rest of the world
as those societies have moved to systems
where individuals can share in success
the results have been more rapid growth
than the world has ever seen and that
growth will not continue forever much of
the growth comes from convergence it
comes from catch
up and after you grow fast enough long
enough there's no longer room for you to
catch up but with standards of living in
China still where they were in the
United States in the 1920s there is
substantial room for this progress to
continue there's no guarantee that it
will continue though environmental
challenges the challenges of avoiding
the kind of financial problems that
setback the United States during the
Depression the challenges of maintaining
a political system that is on the one
hand authoritarian and based on central
control along with an economy that
depends upon information being
disseminated widely will be a great one
for the Chinese no one can say how this
story will end but we know enough to
know that it will be a very big story of
our time we know enough to know that it
is a story that is about progress
through knowledge and we know enough to
know that if you want to be part of the
adventure of our times it's a story you
want to understand and be part of
there's a second thing a second aspect
of this time that I believe will be
remembered for a very long time to come
and that is the revolution that is
underway in the sciences especially in
the information sciences and the life
sciences the way in which we bring them
together you know if you think about it
through much of history medicine has
preceded as much by luck and trial and
error as anything else
Fleming found penicillin more or less by
accident as a mold Jenner found the
smallpox vaccine by stumbling on
something with cattle we're now at the
brink of a very different approach to
understanding human health and to
improving the human condition for the
first time we have sequenced in the last
decade the human genome the map that
describes our common humanity
it's a code that's written in four
letters ATC and ug the bases that are
part of DNA you can think of the human
genome as a book of several million
pages if you go to page two million six
hundred thousand four hundred and fifty
three you go down fourteen lines you go
over eleven spaces and you have a tea
instead of an A
then you may well have cystic fibrosis
that's a kind of understanding of the
disease process that is at an entirely
different level of rigor than we've had
before and it points to prospects for
intervention for change unlike any that
we have seen before no one can know all
that will be possible but for the first
time it is imaginable that we will find
cures for dementia that we will enable
people to repair their hearts that we
will stop labeling cancers by where they
take place in the body and instead
identify them by the type of tumor and
have an appropriately targeted agent for
each type of tumor these are likely to
be years of remarkable progress in
physical health and they may be even
more remarkable years of progress in
mental health as we come to understand
brain functioning better and better the
process of medicine will be transformed
just as information technology
transforms what we think of as routine
life maybe it provides some perspective
or maybe it will just make you think of
me as ancient but I remember very well
giving a speech in Chicago in 1988 and I
was to give a speech to a given group
and a car picked me up at the air
to take me to my speech I got into the
backseat of a car and there was a
telephone in the backseat of the car and
that was something so exciting to me
that I called everyone I knew to say
that I was in the backseat of a car with
a telephone and they shared my
excitement because it was that novel in
1988 just 23 years ago today
more than half the people on earth have
access to cell phones in large parts of
the world
there will never be landline networks
created cell phones will simply be a
leapfrog technology and a leapfrog
technology that will be used in the way
we are accustomed to thinking about cell
phones to talk to text but also in large
parts of the world your bank account
will reside on your cell phone you will
transfer money using your cell phone you
will monitor your children using your
cell phone and so forth we don't know
all the places that individuals will
take information technology it was a
revelation 40 years ago when
sociologists formulated the observation
of six degrees of separation when they
formulated the observation that it was
for people to be connected almost any
two people in the world with six links I
know you you know someone else that
person knows someone else and so far
that was a kind of theoretical
possibility now with social network
people find their way along those chains
and find their way very rapidly no one
thought in 1960 that the world would
have use for as many as a hundred
computers the people who first found the
copying machine didn't see that it would
be pervasively used because mimeograph
was available we can't yet know where
the degree of connectivity that social
networks make possible we'll take things
but we can know that those effects are
likely to be very very large it's a
feature of exponential growth of steady
percentage growth that the increment of
change that takes place gets larger and
larger each year and that's what happens
with knowledge as we know more and more
even if each bit of knowledge is only
expanded at the same rate the total
accretion to knowledge each year becomes
that much greater and that's why we are
likely to see as much scientific
progress in the next quarter century as
we've seen in the entire previous
century now these are not unrelated
developments that I am talking about
here
scientific and technical progress and
these changes in standards of living
that I have described precisely the
reason we are able to see more rapid
progress than ever before is because
there is more technological progress
more that can be emulated than ever
before so far and I've talked about what
people will look at when they look at
our time I have emphasized what in a
sense is external to the individual
external to the human heart I've talked
about rapid growth in some parts of the
world all that that may mean for the
global system I've talked about progress
in science and technology there's
another difference and it's a difference
that has been underway for many many
years but it may also be accelerating
and that is an ever widening sphere of
human concern and human compassion I
think about the fact that a half century
ago at the places where you might be
likely to listen to this tape there
would have been very very
you african-american students some there
might have been no african-american
students institutions like Harvard and
Yale did not have women students and
even allied colleges had numbers of
women that were a quarter of the number
of men who were studying homosexuality
was a crime in every one of the 50
states and the idea that gay soldiers
could fight in the military or that gay
people could be married would have been
an inconceivable kind of notion the idea
that those with mental illness had
rights to be involved in shaping their
care the idea that those with serious
medical illness had right to be told
what their condition was none of these
were norms in our society the set of
concepts that we were prepared to accept
as objects of our sympathy was far more
limited than it was today here's a great
question that I hope you will all think
about it was asked of my daughter as we
sat at a dinner in Washington I asked my
daughter he said Ruth a hundred and
fifty years ago sitting in this room we
took sleigh
every as absolutely natural and for
granted and that seems inconceivable
today it is unlikely he said and I think
he was right that we have reached some
apex of civilization now what is it that
we do that seems natural to us that will
seem barbaric a hundred years from now I
don't know what the answer to that is
perhaps it is aspects of the way we
treat the poor with a very young or the
very old perhaps it has to do with the
ways in which we treat animals perhaps
it has to do with the ways in which
superstition continues to shape our
approaches to important human problems I
don't know the answer but it would be
very surprising if there are not
important aspects of how we live today
that will shock the conscience --is of
those who look back on us just as our
conscience azar shocked by those who
came before and what will change those
conscience --is it will be individuals
it will be protests it will be ideas it
will be philosophies it will be better
thinking than the thinking that came
before
this is the reason you are here in a
university you are here to be educated
you are here to understand thinking
better and to think better yourself it's
not a chance you're gonna have
throughout your lifetime believe me you
will have a job it will be enormous ly
fulfilling but it will come with a set
of tasks some of it will be about
thinking but all of it won't be about
thinking but for the next few years you
have a chance to focus on thinking I
think about some of the students who
I've had a chance to know over the years
who took advantages of their
opportunities in a university one of the
stories I always like to tell is of a
Freshman Seminar that I had a chance to
teach at Harvard when I was president of
the University I taught a seminar on
globalization some of the issues have
just referred to actually and I assigned
a reading that I had written a lecture
that I had given to the American
Economic Association when I was the
United States Treasury secretary about
global capital flows and as I did each
week I asked one of the students to
introduce the readings and this young
man in October of his freshman year said
something like the following the reading
by president summers on the flow of
capital across countries
it was kind of interesting but the data
did not come close to supporting the
conclusions and I thought to myself what
a fantastic thing this was in how many
human institutions that have ever
existed
could somebody who had been there for
five weeks
tell the person who had the title
president that he didn't really know
what he was talking about and have
nobody even find it to be very
surprising and it was a special moment
no I don't want to be misunderstood I
explained to my student that I actually
thought he was rather more confused than
I was and I argued back but what was
really most important about that was
that universities stand out as places
that really are about the authority of
ideas you see it in faculty members who
are pleased when their students make a
discovery that undermines a cherished
theory that they had put forward you see
it when professors will suggest topics
to students but they like it best when
students find their own topics to write
about to think about to study
I I don't believe that there are ideas
that are beyond question I believe
profoundly in academic freedom but
academic freedom does not include
freedom from criticism I believe that
the greatest mistakes come when people
think the Emperor may now may have no
clothes but they're not willing to put
the question because it will shock or
will offend so I think it is enormous ly
important that every idea be open for
discussion but it's a very careful
balance that has to be struck between
the idea that some ideas should be off
limits and beyond challenge which i
think is very wrong and the alternative
perspective which is very common that
all ideas are equally valid that I have
my perspective and you have your
perspective and that's just the way it
is there's usually a right answer you
get to that right answer by debating by
looking at evidence by thinking things
through as hard as you can and there's
no question where that shouldn't be
possible in a university you are
embarked in a university where it is the
authority of ideas that is going to be
most important and it is up to you
whether like that student in my seminar
you choose to pursue your own ideas to
put them forward
and do so
with your convictions the students who
are most successful students who get the
most out of their education are not the
ones who copy someone else's path
they're the ones who set their own path
but the paths that matter most are the
paths that involve better understanding
ideas putting forth ideas urging one's
own ideas while being prepared to change
one's mind in the face of evidence and
recognizing that we all have a chance to
be part of the story as the world
evolves from a world governed by the
idea and authority to a much better
world governed by the authority of ideas
thank you
[Music]